- Vol d'oiseau au-dessus
de Parc-Extension.
Quartier dense avec peu d'arbres
et peu d'ombre; c'est un des
secteurs habités où il fait
le plus chaud à Montréal.
Une mer d'asphalte,
de béton et de goudron
qui absorbent la chaleur.
NILSON ZEPEDA, chargé de projet,
Campagne ILEAU, Montréal
- La chaleur qui est emmagasinée
pendant la journée et ensuite
ça la relâche dans l'air durant
la nuit. Ça fait que ça fait
des nuits encore plus
inconfortables. On parle d'une
différence entre 7 à 10 degrés
de température entre un îlo
de fraîcheur et un îlot
de chaleur. Donc, c'est
une immense différence dans
la qualité de vie des gens.
- Elle est aussi flagrante selon
qu'on soit riches ou pauvres.
L'exemple du boulevard l'Acadie
est parlant. Il sépare deux
mondes : à l'est, le gris
de Parc-Extension,
un des quartiers défavorisés
de Montréal. À l'ouest,
la verdoyante vidoyante vidoyane
Mont-Royal qui a une population
beaucoup mieux nantie.
Dre CLAUDEL PÉTRIN-DESROSIERS,
prés., A
- Parc-Extension, Montréal-Nord,
Hochelaga-Maisonneuve.
Historiquement, les quartiers
plus défavorisés ont moins
d'arbres de béton.
Il y a comme eu un effort
un peu moindre, là, pour rendre
les espaces de vie agréables.
- Montréal doit donc verdir
les arrondissements qui en ont
le plus besoin. Un exemple
souvent cité a été réalisé il y
a 10 ans. C'est ce petit par
de la Voisinerie dans Montréal-
Nord, entouré d'immeubles
à logements modiques. Il a
remplacé une section d'un grand
stationnement au grand bonheur
de plusieurs résidents.
JESSE HÉBERT, résident
- C'est niaiseux à dire,
mais si tu pars d'ici,
puis tu t'en vas juste
sur le trottoir, tu n'as plus
l'impression à cause du bruit
des oiseaux, l'air, le bruit des
feuilles qui planent dans le
vent. Tu n'as plus l'impression
d'avoir la même air que quand
tu es en arrière, tu sais.
DANIEL BISSONNETTE, résident
- C'est beaucoup plus frais,
en tous cas.
- Vous le remarquez?
- Oh, oui énormément,
énormément! Énormément! Puis,
je veux dire, on est entourés
de végétation comme... je veux
dire, ça ne se peut pas.
- Il y a une limite à ce que
le corps peut tolérer comme
chaleur. Et on sait que
les îlots de chaleur, bien ça
vient avec un stress important
sur le csur le csur le csur le s
cardiovasculaire. Donc, s'il y a
quelqu'un qui vit dans un îlot
de chaleur à Hochelaga-
Maisonneuve ou à Montréal-Nord
a 2 fois plus de risques
de décéder des conséquences
de la chaleur qu'une personne
qui vit à Outremont
ou à Westmount.
- La bonne nouvelle, c'est que e
les initiatives de verdissement
se multiplient comme jamais.
Ce 22 juin, on enlevait
une partie d'asphalte dans cette
ruelle voisine de l'autoroute 40
pour en faire une te.
L'organisme Ville en vert,
qui est derrière le projet,
intervient dans trois
arrondissements du nord
de la ville.
CLÉMENTINE MOSDALE, charg. proj.
Vert le e en vert
- Sur 2021, on a participé
à 10 projets. On a planté
140 arbres et 316 autres
végétaux. Donc ces autres
végétaux, ça va être tout
st plantesst plantesst plantess,
des arbustes et puis des
vivaces.
tine Mosdale nous avait
donné rendez-vous au Parc Jarry.
Le Stade IGA, les courts
de tennis voisins et les
stationnements forlot
de chaleur au milieu du parc.
- On voit que c'est un grandespu
d'arbres. Donc, nous,
on a planté des arbres
pour apporter de l'ombrage
et puis pour apporter
plus de fraîcheur.
- 18 nouveaux arbres et quelques
plantes grimpantes le long des
tennis oé plantés.
- On sait que un arbre peut
fournir de l'oxygène pour
quatre personnes. Donc, je
dirais que tout geste compte!
- Des arbres diversifiés, il
faut miser sur la biodiversi
pour éviter une crise comme
celle de l'agrile du frêne.
(bruit de scie et fracas)
- L'épidémie de l'agrile du
frêne, combiné à l'urbanisation,
ont d'ailleurs fait reculer
Montréal. Une récente étude
de Statistique Canada a conclu,
en utilisant des i
satellites, que la ville
comptait plus d'espaces verts
en 2001 qu'en 2019.
MARIE-ANDRÉ MAUGER, resp.
transition écologique, V. de Mtl
- On aaucoup d'arbres,
mais on a dû en abattre
plusieurs dizaines de milliers
à cause de l'agri
L'agrile du frêne, c'est un
problème qui est moins agressif
en ce moment, mais qui continue
d'être
- Au cours de la dernière année,
Montréal a encore dû abattre
10 000 frênes.
- Un impact énorme parce qu'il
faut partir de la base qu'un
arbre mature est un arbre qui
est beaucoup plus efficace
en terme de lutte contre
ts de chalts de chalts de chalt.
- Quand il y a une place sur
rue, on
- En mode rattrapage, la Ville,
dans son nouveau plan climat,
s'est donc engagé à planter
500 000 nouveaux arbres d'ici
2030, soit 50 000 par année.
- On vient de publier le bilandn
climat 2020-21 où on sait
qu'on a planté un peu plus de
40 000 arbres. Donc, on est à un
peu moins de 10 % de notre
cible, mais on est
sur la bonne voie.me fie au nome
de projets qu'il y a ici
et à quel point ce qui se fait
à Montréal est inspirant
dans d'autres villes, on peut
considérer qu'on est vraimentsu.
- Mais le gros du travail reste
encore à faire pour lutter
contre les îlots de chaleur.
Et il sera important :
un rapport de Ressourcesnaturele
que Montréal, en 2070,
devrait connaître 27 jours
de 30 degrés et plus dans
l'année. C'est trois fois plus
qu'aujou